hey
is that one of those fancy coffee cups
that stays warm it heats it from the
bottom
that's my friend cleo who is a newly
independent journalist making stuff on
youtube and i'm going to call it
huge if true there aren't a lot of
journalists youtubers out there and now
that there's another one i'm gonna ask
for her help
okay
so i wanna show you a map
do you see this map yes
this is the congo it's this giant
country in central africa that used to
be called zaire
and what's crazy about this that i've
never seen before is if you map all of
the mines in congo it looks like this
and all of these are the cobalt mines
cobalt cobalt yes cobalt it's a thing
that used to not be important at all but
it's now very important and that's what
i'm like sort of fixating on right here
these are cobalt mines and 15 of them
are run
by china
i know where this is going but wait this
isn't another just china moves into
africa story made a video on that
this story feels bigger like we're going
through some shift in how we make and
use energy we are going to transition
this country into the future which means
we're using new materials new materials
like cobalt
so the question is who's going to
control these new valuable minerals in
the future
and how will they use that control oh
because cobalt is in electric car
batteries and a bunch of other stuff yes
bingo electric car batteries the thing
that everyone is racing to figure out
and make more of i mean look at this
chart of the demand for evs over time
like it's just exploding
so
the reason i'm showing you all of this
is because you're a technology person
you think about this stuff and you tend
to have a more sort of optimistic view
than i do on a lot of the future
and i kind of want that perspective here
because what i see here is just another
instance of like a big superpower china
racing into an underdeveloped country to
steal its resources so that it can
control the supply chain and to be
honest i thought the clean energy
revolution would look
i don't know different different than
this
i wasn't expecting this
i really do think that it can i think
that there's a world in which there's a
green energy revolution that doesn't
look like the same old story of all the
other fossil fuels and minerals that
we've mined before
um i don't think it's going to be easy
but i think there are ways to pull it
off
i like your optimism well let's get into
it i want to show you what i've learned
here on cobalt because i've sort of been
like down a rabbit hole on the cobalt
china situation
and then i want to like have a
discussion about what this means for the
future of energy
that children were mining cobalt in the
democratic republic of congo or drc
cobalt is one of the world's most
coveted resources its value has nearly
tripled over the past year this most
precious of minerals is often extracted
and sorted by tiny the chinese traders
here bought all the cobalt and sold it
mainly to one chinese company
okay hold on one second i need to thank
today's sponsor who is nordvpn
a vpn is a tool that allows you to
connect to the internet but not through
the place that you're at you can do it
through a different country why would
you want to do this well i use nordvpn
when i'm traveling when i'm in different
countries and i want my internet
connection to route through the united
states so that my email and all my like
logins don't think i'm like someone from
a different country trying to log into
my stuff
but i also use it when i'm in the united
states and want to log in via other
countries so i can access way more
content way more stuff that i don't have
access to in the us but i do if i
connect through britain nordvpn is a
very easy smooth quick way of doing all
of this nord also has a major focus on
security and encryption so that your
internet connection is always secure oh
and it doesn't cost very much money
there's a link in my description it's
nordvpn.com johnny harris clicking that
link supports this channel but it also
gets you an exclusive deal oh and if you
decide that it's not useful to you for
any reason
within 30 days you can get all of your
money back so go try it out go see if
this can expand your entertainment
options help you connect to the internet
more securely
etc thank you nordvpn for sponsoring
this video
let's get back to it
so first let's understand what cobalt is
it's this blue mineral that's become
really important in the past few years i
mean just look at the price of cobalt
since 2010 it's like popped off in these
last few years because of one thing
electric cars are expected to double the
world's demand for cobalt by the year
2025. i want to continue to explain
cobalt and china and all that but like
first we have to understand the drc the
democratic republic of the congo this
massive country in the middle of africa
that honestly should be one of the
richest countries on earth because it is
sitting on top of so many valuable
resources
unfortunately
this is a place that for centuries has
not been able to actually take advantage
of this wealth because it has been
pillaged by outsiders whether that's the
people being literally stolen and
shipped across the atlantic as forced
labor or this brutal belgian king who
came in and forced the congolese people
to work to harvest rubber or more
recently the blood diamond rush i mean
this place has been pillaged for years
because of its resources so here we are
in 2022 the new hot commodity is not
rubber or diamonds it's cobalt
this blue mineral that used to be just
like for making ceramics turn blue like
that's what it was useful for
but now it has a really useful purpose
in the growing world of electric
vehicles electric vehicles a lot of
people love tesla well this is the ev
sales forecast electric vehicles are the
future so i know something about how
electric car batteries are made i kind
of know the things that go into them how
did a substance that made ceramics blue
end up being so important to electric
car batteries well at first lithium is
like the main ingredient and like that
was the most important but as
more and more car companies are trying
to make their cars go longer and further
without exploding
cobalt is this amazing material that
helps regulate the heat
and like volatility of an ev so cobalt
is super important for electric cars to
be able to go long distances without
needing a recharge or
exploding absolutely we're in this phase
where like every car company is
competing on these sort of nuanced like
marginal improvements like my car can go
400 kilometers mine can go 410 and so
cobalt is becoming more and more
important for these long range features
that are becoming important in this like
cut throat competition turns out that
the congo
has 70
of the world's cobalt like i'm not
kidding when i say this place is like
resource rich you're rich so this is
becoming a bigger and bigger issue but
guests who read the tea leaves like 20
years ago and started investing in
cobalt mines in the congo china china
yes obviously
china the democratic republic of congo
struck a big deal with beijing chinese
traders here bought all the cobalt and
sold it mainly to one chinese company
this is where i start to get pessimistic
about the whole green energy revolution
and let me tell you why i made this
video a while back about how china has
been rushing into africa to build up a
bunch of infrastructure and to win the
hearts of african nations but also to
kind of assert control and leverage over
them but as a part of all of this
chinese investment in africa china has
been pouring loads of money into mines
specifically focusing on the drc where
all these minerals are
and again this is like the early 2000s
they set up all of these mines and
started mining and processing cobalt if
you look at a chart of ev demand it goes
way up in the 2000s how did they know
like why would china show up and start
mining cobalt if it wasn't particularly
valuable yet
yeah and that's a really important
question and the answer just sort of
blew my mind the first one's easy which
is that
cobalt became useful for other things
like like cell phone batteries and
things like that so there already was
sort of like some nascent demand there
but it's also because of how china's
economy works because china is a
communist country where the state and
the economy are like intertwined they
have different incentives than the
capitalist west like in our economy we
have independent corporations who focus
on delivering
short-term profits to shareholders
in china they can take long-term bets
they can say like in 20 years we think
that this is going to be really valuable
so we're going to pour tons of money
into this because we don't need to
deliver profits next quarter we can
deliver profits in 20 years so it gives
them this unique ability to make big
bets that could potentially be huge and
in this case
it was the absolute best bet they could
have made we hit the jackpot here so all
of this explains why china controls 15
out of the 19 cobalt mines in the drc
okay so you got
electric vehicle demand going up cobalt
is necessary for electric vehicles and
you've got china with their foresight
buying up all of these mines in the
congo to control the supply of cobalt
which we're going to need for evs yes
that is exactly right and this gets into
the strategy and the geopolitics of all
of this there's this one quote from an
expert that politico interviewed he says
that china is not processing all of that
cobalt to export it to the united states
to support your electric vehicle
revolution
they're gonna make cheap cars themselves
and the best that you can hope for is
that they'll export those cheap cars to
you like it's just so clear that like
they're doing this to control what they
see as a massive burgeoning market that
they want to have a corner on and and
they're doing it and here we go with why
i feel so disappointed as i learn about
all of this like here you have china
racing to control this valuable mineral
so that they can have leverage and power
as the world transitions to cleaner
energy oh and not to mention that as
china shows up and does all of this
cobalt mining you'll see no regard for
worker safety you'll see super dangerous
minds you'll see children doing back
breaking work you have people routinely
dying on the job and perhaps the biggest
contradiction of all
is that this is a finite resource once
again oh and the process of mining and
refining this stuff is the same old
story of deforestation polluted rivers
and just general exploitation i mean i
thought the sustainable green revolution
was going to be like clean and just for
people i thought electric cars would
actually mean a cleaner way of doing
business like a cleaner future
but instead we're seeing the same old
earth destroying great power resource
race that got us here in the first place
you good yeah my rant is over i'm sorry
i just this has like gotten me really
worked up
and uh i i'm ready to like chill out now
[Music]
when i used to imagine a clean energy
future i had this image in my head right
of like
that moment in every sci-fi where they
go like once we lived in harmony
and there's wakanda and there's that one
chobani ad where everyone is using
technology and living in a beautiful
farm
record scratch freeze for him here we
are in the real world where
right now it totally is the same old
story of exploitation and harm to the
environment in different ways and harm
to people
i think one thing that's important to
realize is that when we talk about a
cleaner future we're specifically
talking about less co2
and so though it conjures up all of
these images of clean in other ways it's
on us to do that also there's nothing
about the technology that inherently
will bring that about oh dear what can
we do we have a few things that we can
do the first is we can change the kinds
of batteries that we're using there's a
lot of development in new kinds of
batteries one of them is a lithium iron
battery not a lithium ion battery
there's an extra r in there and that
battery uses different kinds of minerals
it doesn't use any cobalt
that might help this specific example
but the reality is that most of these
minerals have their own stories of
exploitation so it's not
it's not great
so here's where i start to feel pretty
optimistic there's a big difference
between fossil fuels and minerals you're
right that the difference between
electric vehicles and gas combustion
vehicles is that one uses fossil fuels
and the other we're swapping out fossil
fuels for minerals but there's a big
difference between fossil fuels and
minerals namely fossil fuels are being
incinerated every time that we drive if
we're using more minerals to power our
cars we also have the opportunity to get
a lot better at recycling
this shows how much we already recycle
this is end-of-life recycling rates for
select metals in electric car batteries
oh so we're already recycling a lot of
these including cobalt like it's almost
40 percent yes and the other thing to
keep in mind here is you don't need to
recycle these minerals and metals in
cars themselves you could have a clean
energy future where we're recycling
metals and minerals from batteries that
store wind and solar energy into
electric cars that are then re-recycled
back out into other forms of storage and
batteries
interesting okay wow yeah that is a like
optimistic view of batteries because it
just feels so finite but if like the
lifespan is dramatically higher like
that becomes a much more useful and less
resource intensive proposition there's
also one more possibility and i think
that people will call me a little bit
pie in the sky here but i'm okay with
that i think it's possible that it may
not just be about fixing the problem
with cars but also about fixing the
problem of cars there's a high-tech
version of this where self-driving cars
there's some research and speculation
that they might reduce the amount of
cars that we're using total there's also
a lower tech version of this where we
just invest more in public transport
that might sound unsexy but it
really does seem to me like the most
promising option
i think also if you zoom out for a
second and think about why we care about
climate change
yes we care about animals and we care
about the
planet itself but we also care a lot
about human suffering one of the reasons
why so many people care about climate
change is because it will cause human
suffering it already is and so if you
take this story and you look at the
human suffering caused by mining and you
then say oh we're not going to try and
solve this problem we're just what gonna
let more climate change happen we have
to solve these things at the same time
because both will
will hurt more people basically yeah
that's a really good point i think
that's a i think if there's like two
major takeaways
that i take from from your research into
this it's like
number one
a greener future is not
inherently
a
cleaner more idealistic happy future it
just is like a less co2 future which is
like again
obvious it's like so obvious when you
say it like that and make that
differentiation but like i had those so
deeply bound together
but i think the more important idea is
like even though i have a pessimistic
view of like great power rivalry
there's not an option here like
there's no scenario in which throwing up
my hands and being like
the world's effed is like
gonna do anything and it's like it's in
fact it's the easier way out in a lot of
ways
and so
it's good to know that there is like
real work being done to try to solve
this and that it's not just like bound
to go down the same route in my mind
this story isn't a cleaner future is
just as bad
it's a cleaner future is a cleaner
future
with problems that we still have to
solve
[Music]
you